hi guys and welcome to Friday re a look
back at my week through short snippets
of video also known as video blogs so
here are some of the things that
happened to me this week what happened
to me this week it started in New York
I got to see Chester C's last
performance in Rock of Ages and
celebrate
and then I came back to Los Angeles
hello friary I am back in my house in
Los Angeles and I just finished making
our the shooting my video for Wednesday
it's currently 11:20 proof I have to be
at the YouTube space tomorrow 9:00 a.m.
to shoot some more and not too deep
episodes we shot two today which was
really excited oh I didn't explain any
of this to you I flew back from New York
today this morning and then got off a
plane went to the YouTube space and shot
two really really fun episodes of not
too deep with Kingsley and Andrea
Russett they're just great people
they're really really cool awesome
people and I'm so happy that they agreed
to be on the show
so I can't wait for those episodes to go
up I want to show you guys this I came
home and my mom and my stepdad stayed in
my house over New Year's because they
had already been planning to come out to
LA for New Year's and so it just worked
out that they could stay here cuz I was
going back to New York and I came back
and my mom left all of these really
sweet encouraging notes everywhere this
is what happens when I when I am ready
early hehehe meaning that she had time
to do all of this one here your yard
wonderful spectacular fantastic home we
miss you in Jersey but we understand our
hearts we love you you are the best
daughter in the whole world see they're
so nice that if they almost feel sorry
now that I'm reading them out loud to
you guys I feel like maybe my mom is
just playing one cruel joke I mean I'm
just kidding I love you mom thank you
for cleaning up my whole house because
it's so nice and clean in here and then
I just destroyed it I'll see you at the
YouTube space tomorrow
I just gotta remember to film what is
like what is happening with the shadows
and sunglasses and all of it good
morning it is 8:15 a.m. and we are
headed to the YouTube space to shoot two
more episodes of not too deep today's
episodes are going to be with colleen
ballinger
who I think is the greatest human being
and then Harley from Epic Meal Time who
is also a superhuman and I haven't seen
him for a while so I'm excited to see
him but I'm trying to write questions
for the podcast interviews on the way
over to the podcast right now so I'm
literally voice my mowing myself on my
phone questions like which member of One
Direction would you want to pour a bowl
of cold soup over the head of it's a
really hard-hitting podcast if you
haven't listened to it yet please go
check it out I just got to do Pete on
this podcast
yeah that's proof
it's great it's great it's great
should we ships sure we got we shipped
ourselves I think is illegal in terms of
the internet but we did it anyway
and after a long dry spell finally shot
with two idiots two named Hannah and
mamrie Hart got two very intense adults
talking about a mustard
change-of-address that had us go cheap
I'll call the mustard people too
we're shooting a trio of videos once
this mustard spectacular gets settled
it's real intense here no one knows why
this is happening okay and then today I
went to a top-secret video shoot
good morning it's Friday and I'm on the
shoot and guess who got flown in Secret
Service style for this shoot these on
the way school it's so weird and you're
wearing a dress like confusing things
happening this morning we're eating
lunch now unsaid that's really
attractive
that's perfect these guys are here party
party party party party party party
party party party party party party
party party
oh so normal it's all normal it's all
normal it's just a bunch of normal
humans hanging out with the camera in
the bathroom I always use the restroom
for with the five to ten of my favorite
cameramen so spoiler this is my now just
walking down the street in Burbank
filming something that exciting
wearing this yep
and then I got that weirdo back you got
done a very long shoot day today and it
was fun it was super fun I saw a lot of
really great people and worked on a
really cool project that you guys will
see soon and guess who is back tonight
this little oh wow machine you know a
snort factory you're a little short
factory hi hello hello yeah get it get
the moon oh jeez she's such a tease we
just went out and played fetch there you
go that was my week I hope you enjoyed
it if you didn't enjoy it that's okay I
don't enjoy scary movies ghosts didn't
like the ending of gone girl so we all
have things that we don't like and
that's okay
no haste don't forget that I am coming
to the UK to do some book signings and
I'm really excited about them and all
the informations down below and don't
worry I will take photos and sign books
for everyone that shows up at these
signings that's my goal my intention and
hopefully the result of what happens so
please check them out and other than
that like this video if you liked it
subscribe if you haven't already because
sometimes we forget to do things that we
think we've already done but seem like
practical knowledge then you're like oh
my god I totally forgot to wear pants or
like I totally forgot to shave my
armpits on the day that my gym class is
only dancing to that song shout gym
classes have gone where y'all okay I'm
going I'm leaving